plus des prix du lait a mis en
difficulté un certain nombre
d'exploitations laitières pour permettre
une meilleure rémunération des
producteurs de lait une marque a été
créée c'est qui le patron aujourd'hui le
concept se développe pour les
producteurs de salades
reportage à châteauneuf-sur-loire 125 g
de salades emballé sous cellophane un
produit alimentaire
apparemment anodin en apparence
seulement car ce sachet s'inscrit dans
la lignée de la marque c'est qui le
patron
après le lait jus de pomme le steak
haché
c'est la salade qui vient de voir ses
critères et priorités rigoureusement
établi par les consommateurs on a
toujours interrogé le consommateur sur
ses choix ses attentes
mais là aujourd'hui le magasin et les
consommateurs ont justement choisi
d'avoir une salade de saison sera donc
la mâche en hiver la batavia l'été et à
l'automne de la scarole sans être bio le
produit sera cependant issus de
l'agriculture raisonnée et cultivés en
plein champ cette salade a en outre
l'obligation d'être éco responsable ça
veut dire en production une agriculture
raisonnée qui utilisent le moins
possible de produits phytosanitaires et
ensuite en transformation à lavage avec
un taux de chlore réduit et puis on
progresse que de transformation qui
respecte au mieux la salade
éco-responsable certes mais comme tous
les produits c'est qui le patron
cette salade inclus obligatoirement dans
son prix une juste rémunération des
producteurs le prix qui a été déterminé
par les consommateurs permet de
rémunérer de manière plus forte
le producteur
d'un point de vue concret 10 % de plus
sur le prix d'achat des matières ce qui
va représenter à peu près 50 % de marge
supplémentaire pour le producteur
depuis le début de ce mois partent d'ici
les salades c'est qui le patron pour
alimenter les enseignes casino et auchan
de la moitié nord de la france
nous sommes allés tri de saint denis de
l'hôtel dans le loiret se sont pas trop
qui a lancé la marque c'est qu'ils
battront l'an passé ombre pas la
lectrice
bonjour bonjour alors comment cette
marque est née
en fait cette marque est née au moment
de la crise de la crise du lait les
producteurs étaient dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée et puis nous ça
fait des années qu'on essaye de trouver
une voie différente en fait à
l'écoulement de notre production
laitière au travers de la marque centre
val de loire et c'est donc on a en fait
rencontrer un homme qui s'appelle
nicolas chavanne et on a émis donc sur
internet un questionnaire qui finalement
implique le consommateur en lui posant
un certain nombre de questions de la
conception qu'il a deux sont produites
son acte d'achat
la société du social etc donc les
consommateurs ont pu répondre à ce
questionnaire ont élaboré un cahier des
charges ont élaboré un prix de vente du
produit et nous ensuite on a bien sûr
répondu à ceux à ce cahier des charges
au niveau nos producteurs
et puis le produit est partie
effectivement sur un succès extrêmement
fort puisqu'on a vendu 30 millions
litres de lait en ce sens la première
année alors cette brique de lait c'était
patron c'est une de vos références parmi
2500 références de l'entreprise quel est
concrètement la différence pour le
consommateur s'il achète ça ob de
n'importe quelle autre alors il ya il ya
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent être
différentes c'est à dire qu'on est à
l'origine par exemple qui peut être une
une chose différente il ya la manière de
les pratiques d'élevage
donc on va être avec une augmentation
d'un ogm on tient bien sûr aussi
énormément
entre du bien être animal il ya aussi
l'emballage on va voir de la brique la
bouteille sans bouchons etc
donc c'est toute cette élaboration
évidemment qui va répondre avec les
charges de nos clients qui vont être
soit des clients distributeurs soient
des industriels soit dans le cas de la
marque du consommateur cette coopérative
de consommateurs qui disent bas nous
c'est ce produit là que nous voulons en
termes de en termes d'évolution
d'accords mets s'écrivent pas trop le
pas 3 c'est vous alors non celle qui le
patron le patron c'est le consommateur
en fait que pourquoi c'est le
consommateur parce que globalement c'est
lui qui va aller dans le magasin et ses
8 imedi et qui va dire je vais prendre
ce produit là et pas un autre
parce que je sais que ce produit-là
correspond à ce que j'ai défini aux
attentes au respect des producteurs au
respect des animaux au respect de
l'alimentation etc
donc ça c'est vraiment un contrat de
confiance et une évolution se produit
c'est un peu un big bang dans la
relation qu'on peut avoir entre des
consommateurs
un industriel des producteurs de lait
est un distributeur également qui
finalement adhère énormément la démarche
je peux vous garantir que au travers de
ce produit là il ya bien sûr de la
fierté vis-à-vis des consommateurs de la
fierté vis-à-vis des producteurs
mais il ya une fierté énorme vis-à-vis
de nos salariés nos collaborateurs sont
enchantés de fabriquer ça parce qu'ils
savent au fond au fond d'eux-mêmes que
ce qu'ils font c'est bien et je pense
que c'est ça cette évolution et qu'on
redonne du sens parce que si on fait pas
ça eh bien demain notre alimentation
sera complètement uniformiser avec des
gros groupes multinationaux qui nous en
poseront leur façon de consommer et nous
on veut pas de ça nous on veut une
diversité d'une diversité alimentaire et
on veut d'un choix alimentaires un choix
qui correspond à nos besoins et sans les
critiques et si ce moment un sens ou
dans l'autre
alors justement au milieu des autres
géants de l'agroalimentaire vous pensez
que votre entreprise peut encore jouer à
fond pour proposer notre alimentation
alors je suis effectivement un goût à
l'échelle européenne ou mondiale de ce
qui peut se donner mais je suis aussi
quelqu'un en france qui a une place
assez significatives au niveau 2 avec
mon entreprise
donc je crois que il faut continuer à
développer effectivement ces idées là et
continue et petit à petit a influencé
finalement nos consommateurs qui sont
autour d'eux parce que au global c'est
eux qui décident c'est eux qui décident
du choix et de l'évolution tel qu est ce
que l'on veut donner
oui j'y crois et sinon je le ferai pas
sinon on aurait effectivement des
solutions mais on voit aussi la voyez là
jusqu'où nous mène la financiarisation
jusqu'où nous mêmes ces choses qui des
fois son denim est complètement de
censure on va mener des projets puis un
moment ces projets sont dilapidés dont
je crois qu'il faut il faut continuer à
construire avec des vraies valeurs qui
sont pas que celle de l'argent qui sont
celles effectivement de la vie en
société du respect des gens de l'envy
qu'on va donner à continuer à mener des
projets parce que c'est quand même ça le
sens de notre activité le sens de notre
histoire
[Musique]